sound of Freedom though it's been
attacked relentlessly by many in the
media it has cracked 50 million with a
current domestic box office of 53
million 920 22 551 and massive Success
Through Word of Mouth more and more
people are starting to see this film it
looks like the amount of uh gross
revenue being generated is increasing
whereas most films have their big
Blockbuster weekend it goes down this is
the inverse I think this film really is
potentially a starting a movement more
and more people are are getting active
focusing on the issue more people care
about the issue there are creepy people
in the media that are smearing it as Q
Anon and other weird things but get this
even with that on Rotten Tomatoes The
Tomato Meter which is the official
corporate press reviewers give it a 75
percent that surprised me the audience
gives it a 100 with over 10 000 verified
ratings